und nun scheint mir zu einer dame die
mit siegfried und roy eine wirklich sehr
einprägsame erinnerung hat und zwar
verona pooth wir freuen uns sehr dass
sie in der leitung sind guten abend na
hallo
man kann es kaum fassen und zwar waren
sie wohl alleine gelassen in einem raum
mit einem der tiger wie kann man sich
das vorstellen
ja ich glaube einfach nicht mit meinen
martin vegas und hoffens die show
angeschaut und wir uns ganz groß
angekündigt aber wir haben schnell
mitbekommen dass wir daten wie man den
sechs freundinnen haben stage eingeladen
ins einige tiger vorgestellt und da war
wirklich ein sehr sehr positives der
angeblich noch ein baby war und kurz was
zu trinken ich glaube die hat sich einen
spaß daraus gemacht wir haben die tür
zugemacht und wir haben mit diesem
wunderschönen weißen tiger der uns in
minuten hätte den speichen künftig ganz
allein im raum
rang und ich haben auch flach beatmet
und nur gehofft dass sie ganz ganz
schnell wiederkommen dann ist alles gut
das glaube ich auf jeden fall der puls
war bestimmt auf 180 und in der zeit wo
sie die beiden kennen gelernt haben
haben sie vielleicht auch einen trick
vor den beiden gelernt was ich von ihm
wirklich gelernt habe ist einfach sie
haben angefangen haben und sie sind
einfach noch ein prüfstein aus einer
zeit wo man wirkliche freunde werden
lassen unter den bedingungen musik groß
geworden sind gibt es heute gar nicht
mehr und der trick war einfach zwischen
21 und liebe und freundschaft immer
weiter zu machen ich muss auch sagen
dass ich die show gesehen habe was mich
am meisten beeindruckt begeistert einige
leute waren ja die war sehr speziell
aber die
die waren zu gehen und zu fragen auch
gesagt das sind wirklich großartige
talente wie ich sie wahrscheinlich so
nicht mehr wieder geben wird
wahrscheinlich nicht wenn sie einen roi
zurückdenken woran denken sie besonders
gerne ja dem ua an den spaß als die ganz
deutschland haben haben viele sender
angefragt wie sie als das oft haben
gesagt gib ihm zu wenn das wetter passt
ja übrigens auch darin pkw wir brauchen
ganz ganz klein ist und ich durfte
diesen tigerbaby mit geben und ich weiß
doch wieder anzog völlig auf meiner hand
gekratzt hat kann mit absicht und da war
auch wirklich gleich ein richtiger
kratzer da hatte ich so ein respekt für
diesen ganz kleinen krieger und dafür
nur meine güte aber ihre freundlichkeit
und dieses unkomplizierte das war schon
wirklich erstaunlich weil das man
einfach so vollprofis und wenn der
vorhang aufging dann waren sie da und
das hat man auch gesehen als frau schon
schwer verletzter und schlaganfall hatte
mit gehstock gehen musste sie waren wir
aus der eifel
er hatte trotzdem dem publikum gestellt
und ich glaube das ist nicht immer so
einfach weil viele stars aus dieser
generation haben sich ja dann nicht mehr
gezeigt wenn sie eltern wurden oder wenn
irgendwas am krankheit gezeichnet hatte
und da habe ich mal genau dass das war
das besondere die beiden und der humor
rein
vielen herzlichen dank für monat für den
moment schönen abend noch